let's answer a few questions before we
wrap this up today
got to find the tweet
scrolling scrolling
had it ready but accidentally closed my
phone wait here it is just a few
questions let's see if there's there's
any actual questions instead of just
some smart alec remarks how difficult
will it be for an unvaccinated player to
get through the season that question
comes from tom marshall also known as at
a red zone alk one of our most loyal
listeners and followers for for years
now
i
i i don't think it will be inordinately
difficult for an unvaccinated player to
get through the season but as i already
mentioned you get tested every single
day if you're not vaccinated if you are
vaccinated you get tested once every two
weeks so
unvaccinated player constant risk that
today is the day that that he's going to
be shut down so it's going to be like
last year for an unvaccinated player and
as the delta variant spreads and his
people have kind of let their guard down
generally about the pandemic and don't
seem to be inclined to put their guard
back up
maybe the risk is greater this year
maybe people will be looser maybe there
will be
less of a degree of
safety that we saw last year and maybe
of the unvaccinated players there will
be a higher percentage who test positive
but the the best way to make yourself
available in as many games as possible
this year clearly and undoubtedly is to
get vaccinated but as i said
nothing is going to change the minds of
those who are determined at this point
to not get the jab
done again mj who gets the playoff buys
and do they make it to the super bowl
remember there's now only one buy per
conference which means one fewer game
that the one seat in each conference has
to play
i think in the nfc
the tampa bay buccaneers have everything
pointing in their favor to be the number
one seed and i understand that a certain
amount of complacency can set in for a
super bowl champion but not with tom
brady who is obsessed now with getting
number eight now that he has seven it's
on to eight once he gets eight it's on
to nine and when you look at the quality
of the rest of the teams in the nfc
i don't know who can challenge them hey
the saints may still be pretty good
after all the saints won the division
last year maybe we're overlooking the
saints maybe they'll win the division
again and the buccaneers have to do it
the hard way like they did in 2020. the
rams
thought they were going to be pretty
good now this cam akers thing changes
that outlook and even so they're caught
in one of the toughest divisions in all
of football maybe one of the toughest
divisions we've ever seen the 49ers
could be really good the seahawks could
be good the packers if aaron rodgers
shows up and plays like he did last year
could be really good i think washington
is going to be better than we think but
i still think the buccaneers have the
best chance to emerge if i had to pick
one now i'd say the bucks is the one
seed afc i got no idea how it's going to
go something i've pointed out before
look at the look at that conference look
at those divisions the teams that are
actual super bowl contenders buccaneers
not buccaneers wrong conference bills
patriots
ravens browns steelers
titans colts
chargers chiefs and then if rogers would
get traded to the broncos
you add them to the list as well
so i have no idea who the number one
seed is going to be in the afc but i
think both one seeds
clearly have an advantage when it comes
to getting to the super bowl last year
we saw the one seed in
the nfc lose in the nfc championship
game whereas the one seed in the afc
managed to hold serve in both games but
but the chiefs didn't have it easy
against the browns they had a little
easier against the bills but uh they got
to the super bowl and look when we see a
super bowl rematch
it's easy to say that now because those
are the two teams that got to the most
recent super bowl but
this year especially
all the work all the effort all the
talent all the assessment all the study
all the everything the sweat the blood
the tears that go into a season
especially in the afc it's going to come
down to
a lucky break
a lucky bounce
a bad call or from the perspective of
the team that benefits from it a good
call it's going to be something screwy
that that i think provides the
difference between the team that emerges
as the one seed and the other teams that
get to the playoffs and i suspect there
will be
teams that could have made it to the
super bowl that don't make it to the
playoffs in the afc
forest edgewood how many teams in the
nfc west make the playoffs this year at
least two
maybe maybe three
and you know sims and i last year were
toying with the idea that all four could
make it and now that there are three
wild cards it's entirely possible i
don't think it's highly likely but it
could happen i'd say that
that
at least two make it at least two
and then injuries become a major factor
in all of this we've seen it already as
i've said multiple times now with cam
acres what other injuries are going to
happen that changes everything that the
injury
angle
makes irrelevant months of talk and
assessment and predictions and it seems
like most years there is that one injury
that just causes you to view a team
differently and changes their fate
dramatically and that could happen to
one of these nfc west teams but if
everyone stays healthy i'd say
at least two possibly three
h.s micken what's a successful season
for the patriots this year i think
getting back to the playoffs
and
winning a game or two in the postseason
i don't see any reason to think this
team won't be much better than last year
they were seven and nine even with
so little talent relative to past
seasons i think they're going to be good
and i think they will make it to the
playoffs and when it's single
elimination time they've got the
coaching staff
they've got the experience at least
institutionally to figure out how to win
those games and not get freaked out in
the moment like some teams do when they
get to the playoffs for the first time
off topic pft pm posse how's the grill
going been grilling anything
particularly good this summer
i've been trying to go a little
healthier chicken instead of sausage
steak the leaner cuts trying to watch
the cholesterol now that the clock is
ticking toward the witching hour of 60.
grilled some asparagus last night
excellent olive oil salt and pepper good
for you a negative calorie food so uh
the grill is a magical device because
even the foods that you otherwise would
not eat if you put them on the grill
they end up tasting pretty damn good
after all so a lot of chicken this
summer and probably some more chicken
coming tonight
all right let's see what else we got
here
last one lee whit what would be a
successful season for the jaguars that's
a great question
the jaguars were 1 in 15 last year
somehow beat the colts to start the
season and lost 15 in a row
now you've got new coaching staff a head
coach with no nfl experience trevor
lawrence rookie quarterback a new gm in
trent balke although he's been a gm
before
i don't know they're in a tough division
with the titans and the colts
i could see them finishing in third
place
i'd say if the jaguars win at least six
games
that is a highly successful season and
that lays the foundation for making the
leap next year i know every team wants
to come into the year saying we have a
chance to make the playoffs and in
theory every team does but for teams
like the jaguars and jets breaking in
rookie quarterbacks 6 and 11
should be something that
creates real hope for next year and
that's what the jaguars have to do i
mean
how quickly the jaguars fell apart after
being on the brink of the super bowl
just a few years ago they are truly
building from scratch and i think if
you're a jaguars fan you just are
looking for signs
that this works that urban meyer belongs
in the nfl that he's not going to burn
out quickly like nick saban did that
he's going to be far closer to jimmy
johnson than some of the other former
college coaches who came to the nfl
under
high expectations whether it's greg
schiano chip kelly or someone else this
year is that test case
is there enough evidence this year to
make me think this is going to work and
if there is
maybe it starts working as soon as 20
22. we'll keep working around the clock
at profootballtalk.com for the rest of
the day we'll do this again tomorrow
thanks as always for some of your time
and we'll talk to you again real soon
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports